of detecting weak signals via testing
yeah thanks and uh thanks for not
leaving in spite of the escape time you
had but so this is joint work with
Richard [ __ ]
so we I'm going to talk about detecting
weak signals by a hypothesis testing
hypothesis testing is a standard
statistics that was the assessing
although recap it just because I
promised AB everything first principles
and weak signals I like to define what
weak signals are and that's one of the
points of the talks right so hypothesis
testing as I said it standard hypothesis
testing so if you're familiar with it
then you know what's coming I'm going to
you say usually you have a null
hypothesis and non null hypothesis but
I'm going to have noise as my null
hypothesis well call it noise and signal
as as the other thing we want to
hypothesis testing is to test whether
what you've got random data is data is a
signal of noise okay so here's an
example it's an example because it's not
the most general thing but suppose you
are n real numbers which are and iid
drawers offer end of one random variable
and I tell you that the random variable
is distributed either according to a
distribution h0 which is call it noise
or distribution h1 call it signal
they're all distributed from the same
they're all iid right I mean so it's
either H naught H 1 for all of them and
your job is to find which one of these
two it is from i they give you the
hypothesis testing we assume they know H
naught H 1 and X the data right the day
of the drawers so all of this is given
anyone to check whether it's signal or
noise that's the task and if we have a
test to check test apply to X so test is
just a subset T of the sample space
samples a set of all possible values of
X if you notice this would be a little
bit of a CS take on things but I mean
it's just a notation off that's just a
verbal description
so Tesla's just a set and events will
also the test aside to t then the test
is positive and they declare X to the
signal so signal is positive noise is
negative okay
perhaps it's the opposite of the
convention if X doesn't belong to a test
set then you say it's negative then it's
declared to be noise you want to be good
with this prediction of it it's noise so
signal to criteria you can measure or
the probability of false positive which
I'll call F P should actually be SP P
various AFP it's the probability that
you set positive wrongly so the
generating distribution was really nice
H naught but you said it passed the test
and false negative is just the
probability that you said negative
whereas it was positive as well as if a
signal and an optimal test is one for
which no that s beats it in both of
these it's a Pareto optimal that's right
so optimal test by that I mean a
paradoxical test for which no other test
improves both FP n FN and the classical
theory tells us this is a Neyman Pearson
lemma than all them all right so access
the data again recap just a notation H
naught is noise hypothesis noise
distribution h1 a signal test is a set
of data that we declared to be positive
it's just a subset of the sample space
and the likelihood ratio is the
probability that you generated X if the
generating distribution with h1 so the
probability that is signal divided by
the probability that it's noise right
and usually take the log of that this is
not x this is just . you take the log of
that LLR it's the log likelihood ratio
is just a lot right so the higher it is
the more likely it is it's from h1
more likely it's positive right so
likelihood ratio
is just a level set of the likelihood
ratio or the log likelihood ratio of you
well so I usually use the log likelihood
ratio is the set of inputs X for which
the log likelihood ratios at least some
tau any table so this could be negative
because it's logged there so positive or
negative so some real number tau and
level set is the likelihood ratio test
name and Pearson lemma tells you that
every likelihood ratio test is an
optimal test and the proof is very short
and simple I won't give you the proof
but it's it's not a very long poof at
all right so so any test which is of
this form
Freddy tau is a optimal test that is you
cannot improve both its F P and F M
false positive and false negative so if
I want this very optimal test I need
only to study likelihood ratio test now
we are going to throw some basically
sort of computer science perspective on
it and put some asymptotics again fairly
simple so you now are going to have an
independent not necessarily iid the
distributions could be different for the
different except they are independent
there are some tonics n is going to
infinity now a test is really think of
it like an algorithm an algorithm should
work for any input length so I'm going
to assume a test is really a family of
tests one for each n and there's a
number of inputs I nom number
independent inputs you get so that's
what a test is now the hypothesis also
depend on n so there are products Vinny
suggests products right product
distributions H naught 1 up to H naught
n so the distributions from which you
generate noise or signal may be
different at different times and
different for the different eyes right I
will see the reason for that and H 1
similarly is a product distribution and
your given data now and your task is
again to identify whether X is from
excess signal or noise
so here we make a sort of a brave
definition if you will so we'll just
define and this is going to be important
again is very simple here's a natural
definition I'm going to define a test
which is really a family of these kinds
of tests to be ideal if ideal is a word
I made up it could be called something
else so his idea if both F P and F and
go to zero then go to infinity so we
would like both the false positive and
false negative probabilities to tend to
zero as I get more independent samples
which which is a natural thing to
require no I don't care for you training
you just and we can worry also about the
rate and so on but this is just for
Scott so the basic question I want to
answer in this talk and in fact give you
a simple answer although the proof will
require somewhat I'll indicate how the
proof course is when when do ideal test
exists that's what we want to ask okay
well we want to ask this not in the
setting of classical hypothesis testing
which I introduced in the first few
slides but assuming signals a week which
I'll tell you what that means
rather than classical hypothesis testing
all the previous way so now I have to
introduce weak signals so there are two
examples to modeling exams I'll give the
lots of examples so we actually listen
to this talk about from astronomers and
made up this thing so there are n
telescopes observing a regions of sky
they may be actually observing several
regions we look at one region and our
job is to decide if their observations
tell us that that particular region is
an interesting region of the sky so that
the astronomer can throw more resources
into observing that region interesting
means signal not interesting is noise
whatever that means in a minute we'll
see that or you could have an anomaly
detection problem where there are n
transactions of a customer and you want
to know is there a possible anomaly of
fraud fraud is a signal and noises not
fraud right so the interesting
observations but interesting
observations in this case or an
ambulance
data in this case do not occur perhaps
each instance but only in rare instances
that's a reason for what we are going to
talk about as weak signals formally the
model weak signals as follows so you
have again this noise is P not to P n
it's just a product right it's just a
direct product of all these
distributions but signal is not just one
distribution P 1 1 P 1 2 and so on so
forth instead it's a weak mixture with a
very low weight epsilon will be small
will be going to 0 very low weight on
the signal distribution if you will and
almost all the weight still on the noise
so it's mostly noise this models not
only these examples but lots of examples
like that so we are given mostly noise
even in the signal all right it's mixed
in and these are everything is to simply
independent we think of epsilon is going
to 0 as n goes to infinity I'll give you
more conditions on epsilon and so I hope
their setup is clear and in this context
of these examples why do you assume the
distribution that every coordinate are
different ok good question I thanks for
asking so in the telescope example
actually it came up so various
observations in the telescope's or not
the same scale I mean they might put our
simplest example you know for our real
number which means different things so
if you think of it as a Gaussian density
the mean and the variance could be
different because they're just doing
different things one is some spectrum
some part of the spectrum and uh there's
another part of the spectrum there's no
reason why they should be iid yeah I
it's not you assume is known right
we all be assumed the distributions are
known so I could have just do a
transform make H not just uniform those
you
the uniform uniform or does no unknown
unknown normal yep and then that's more
or less there is a whole literature in
statistics about three or weak mortals
yeah so precisely this yeah
so actually I should say that I'm not so
familiar with the statistics model so we
can talk about that number one number
two we'll see that we cannot quite
easily transfer what I'm going to say is
not invariant and the transformation
perhaps of the sort you're thinking I
don't know but signal is signal is a
mixture doesn't matter you can transform
it but we'll see how the we'll have to
see how the criterion changes so maybe
you can tell me after I put up the
theorem what is what how it relates to
what is not right now so so far you just
set up we assume that epsilon is a no
let me assume that everything is wrong
it's not h1 data everything is not so
the Chi square distance which was
introduced many times right is is a
distance between distributions it's just
P 1 over P naught minus 1 squared P
naught is 0 of course if they're equal
this was again introduced in various
stocks and di is a chi squared distance
between p di two distributions right
similar noise and these are some of
those and here's the main theorem now we
have to assume some nice let's
conditions which I will tell you what
they are we have the following terms if
epsilon root D goes to 0 then no ideal
test exists it will prove that and there
epsilon T goes to infinity an ideal test
exists so there is a threshold if you
will not shot right this one
not yet but it it says that but you know
there's the distinction to these two
cases there are things in between we
don't address but otherwise with this
threshold this is true
so most I'll spend time trying to give
you the proofs the in principle proof
which I'll give you in a slide or two is
very simple but I'll give you more
detail more details a little bit later
so hopefully the theorem is clear all
I'm saying
so I mean I don't know whether that's
reminiscent of something so in a simple
case when well this is a very simple
case when this is normal means they're
all mean one stream standard deviation 1
T you can calculate this theta of n I
think this was done in various previous
box as well and so we get that an
epsilon is 1 over root n less than 1
over root n no idea test your epsilon
over is is a big growing constant
growing number over root n then there is
an ideal test this case is actually very
simple
to see the ideal test one ideal test one
ideal test it's not the likelihood ratio
test even even things taking the sum of
x i's words but it is a simple case now
in this case actually there's something
stronger should be true which I think
our proof methods will be but I again
come back to this and give you some
references in the above simple case even
when epsilon is constant over root n
there should not be an ideal test that
would be the conjecture that doesn't
follow from this theorem but that that
should be true because well for instance
the mean some of the N Things is C root
n under H 1 under the signal hypothesis
because the mean is one in each right
and this level is 1 over root n but the
variance or the sum of the observations
to standard deviation is more than 0 to
n for the noise case so we conjecture
that let's take this case as well there
is no ideal test which doesn't follow
from this theorem but it's probably
likely to be true and now the question I
can leave you with is root and
reminiscent of a planted clique problem
I'll come back to that and tell you why
it may be
okay so let's pause for a minute I mean
this theorem is clear right it's very
simple again to state
little hassle to prove as you'll see the
in principle food is trivial is just two
slides this is one and there's one more
slide the in principle proof is this the
likelihood ratio we can actually compute
that so the probability of the data
given h1 h1 is a mixture I just put that
in and I get this and probably the most
crucial step this is approximation so 1
plus since epsilon is a small I can
replace it by the sum and so the log
likelihood ratio is just the sum of the
likelihood ratios now this is not the
here in the departure from name in
person so normally these are independent
samples you would expect the likelihood
ratio to be the product but and so log
likelihood will be the sum of likelihood
ratios right I'm sum of log likelihood
ratios but it's not the sum of log
likelihood it's the sum of likelihoods
themselves and this is because epsilon
is small this is crucial okay there's a
departure from what you would do using
normal layman name appears just artifact
of the fact that it's on small errors
the process
so single quality businesses some of
like new ratios of the individual I not
the product and it's like to explain the
proof proof in principle ideas the mean
until the dilemma says that the mean and
the variance also under noise is zero
variance and of noise as well as the
mean under signal of both epsilon
squared D
so I'll go over the proof but I want to
remark you just focus on attention for a
minute
this says under noise the mean is zero
which is not surprising under signal the
mean is the same as the variance under
noise that's all it's saying right I n
it's a it's a direct calculation yeah
what happens is p 0 is just 0 1 and T 1
has a low probability there's a
different support if it has a different
support it might make life easier to do
the test right but you don't see that p1
over p0 is you don't see that I mean it
suffices to see a single instance louder
than 1 and you know that that we're in a
signal case so if well if it has a
different support this epsilon Square D
probably goes to infinity right these
are some of n things so you're saying
that it's checkable easily testable
easily yeah and indeed it would be
falling under the case that epsilon
Square D goes to infinity and therefore
testable easily
okay so we go ask me more questions very
any other questions
so let me go through this calculation
since we have a couple of minutes let me
go through the calculation is just is
just the calculation right that's just
an interval so multiply out that peanut
and that's zero
this is expectation under p1 so you take
that and that's a chi squared distance a
simple calculation you need a one-step
calculation here then the mean under h1
is only an epsilon fraction of p1 1
minus epsilon fraction of P naught and
you do the calculation you get this
so I just this I checked and it's all
correct so now I'm going to state the
I'm going to try to state the theorem
one part of the theorem as I said
niceness assumptions I need the
following assumption so I'm going to
tell them and tell you the assumptions
and then state out state the theorem and
then give you an idea of the proof so
the Chi square distance with a positive
sign basically is I only take the square
of the positive part of what is what it
what is here which is a likelihood ratio
so I take the sum of all the likelihood
ratios again the sum was the character
that was different from the Neyman
theater so I take the sum of the
likelihood ratios the positive part take
the square and take the expectation
that's a positive part this is a
negative part their sum is the overall
Chi square distance right that we had I
have to assume for this proof that D
plus and D minus or the same order of
magnitude so all the positive and the
negative side the likelihood ratio the
deviation is the same you there are
pathological examples you can construct
if some of these things are not true
it's not clear that exactly these
conditions are necessary but they are
sufficient I'm also going to assume that
epsilon root T goes to 0 we assume that
that's the case for the lower bound
right and we are also going to assume
that P 1 is absolutely bounded in terms
of P P naught this will not be true if
the support is different for example
right so we here we assume that P 1 is
absolutely bounded when there is one
lower bound this is the opposite case of
the easily custodians
and we assume that this is little over
10 and we assume epsilon M goes to zero
by the way these assumptions are
satisfied with a lot of room in in
standard cases so the sanity check so
the theorem is under these assumptions
has no idea of test like to prove that
and of course we would appeal to name
and pants and right it suffice us to
show that there is no likelihood ratio
test which is ideal because the best
test or likelihood ratio test it's
enough to consider only those
and for the talk let's pretend that
approximate likelihood ratios and
likelihood ratios are the same the error
I made in that approximation is not very
big again that has to be tackled
so again recall that the mean and noise
is 0 the variance and the noise as well
as the expectation under signal is
epsilon Square D we assumed this we
assumed this therefore the picture is
like here okay so I should have drawn a
bit so that here 0 epsilon squared D is
much smaller than epsilon routine ignore
these for a moment epsilon squared D is
much smaller than epsilon routine if
only I could prove the following things
in fact if only I could prove the
picture there a constant part of the
mass of H naught like mass of H naught
lies so many standard deviations above
the mean so the mean is 0 so you have a
lot of H naught math far out suppose
that's true suppose also it's true that
lot of the h1 mass is on this side of
this that will prove all that if if
those are true there cannot be an ideal
test right so the ideal test would have
to put the threshold somewhere here
so that our site somewhere higher than
here so that it rules out H not math so
it has to put it here or somewhere maybe
it has to rule out of H not mass but if
you put it here a lot of h1 masses under
it and so you'll make a mistake there so
if you're insured little over one
probability of mistake on H not by
putting it here you'd make a constant
probability of mistake on h1 which is
Vanya's so you cannot put a threshold so
that you get that so I have to prove
this I'll have to prove that a lot of H
naught mass lies far out lot of h1 mass
lies close okay these are the things
that we have to prove
intuitively obvious what we have to do
right so intuitively
this under H naught and of noise the
standard deviation is very high so
things lie at least a few standard
deviations out they'll be here now under
signal the mean was very low here so if
things were not terrible some part of
the mouth should lie on this side okay
so intuitively this should be true but
again we have to prove that all right
whether you can come up with
pathological distributions where these
same obviously so even though a lot of
the mass may lie below of little over
one standard deviation as possible
because you are heavily weight from the
other side and similarly for signals you
could go wrong you could go wrong in
both cases so I got to put conditions on
the distribution so that these things
are true and again I'm going to say
again I came up with the conditions in
the last five maybe I remind you of that
and those have to do with directional
chi squared distances and intuitively
they should be good because directional
distances imply you cannot go wrong on
either side right you can't have fat
pathologies one side being really
lopsided so I'll try to indicate a high
level idea of the proof here we want to
show constant part of the mass wise
enough some standard deviations above
mean for noise we need anti
concentration results but actually we
don't need very strong anti
concentration results we need the anti
concentration is just saying that the
mass was not too concentrated because we
want it to spread out a few standard
deviations
and here you only need the Paley segment
there I'm the basic theorem right which
says for any non-negative random
variable that we have that oh this is Z
we have that the probability that Z is
greater than the expected value over two
is at least as much so as long as that a
second moment you can say that with some
probability it is a few standard
deviations out or at least sorry it's
half the mean out now we're going to use
this with Z in our case equals log
likelihood ratio squared what peléan
segment will only tell us that so we are
using a little R squared for that it
will only tell us that see part of the
mass is either above or below the mean
right it wouldn't tell us which way we
will only tell us one other two ways has
enough mass right so we want to say that
there is enough mass on the higher side
so we'll have to take the positive part
of the log likelihood ratio positive
part this max of 0 and this and take the
square of that and then we have to apply
it now this is where we use assumption
about D plus one sided chi-squared
distance we needed that assumption for
this also we need to upper bound z
squared which is 1/4 moment of the
positive part which we upper bound by
the fourth moment per se so we need to
bound the fourth moment of the likely
log likelihood ratio and I of course
won't do it in the lecture all this
works out based on the assumptions the
fourth moment is bombed it so believe me
on that so this says that the noise
quite a bit of noise is one standard
deviation more than the mean so far well
we need also the signal signal is a bit
harder to deal with because it's the
mixture so technically there is more
complication we also need a constant
part of the h1 mass lies below its mean
by quite a bit
and here we don't we can't okay
turns out we cannot easily compute the
positive part Chi square distance
all the negative parts we have to do
something else it turns our basically we
can do it using the first two moments
for for the signal so for the noise we
use up to fourth moment for the signal
only the first two moments
[Applause]
any questions
okay so I actually come tomorrow that's
the end of it but let's see there are a
couple more slides so we won't run short
of slides so the so here are open
questions there are several open
questions and I'll then also remark on
related literature which may answer some
of the questions that people have
so one open question is just a bit of
setting so suppose they have not one
source so here we had one source and we
had to test whether it came from
hypothesis H naught H 1 instead we might
have M sources and so sauce-i emits
these let's say that these are all
independent and we want to decide which
sources or noise and we chose it
correctly for all of them now if each
source is a row of a matrix it's useful
to consider the situation where the
columns of the data matrix or held by
different processes so in the telescope
example there are n telescope telescopes
or columns rows or regions of the sky so
there are many regions waving that are
being observed and the telescopes which
are columns are holding the data they
observed and you can think of
communication as being precious so you
have to you can worry about how much
communication do the telescopes have to
do among themselves so as to find if
each Rose a signal or noise so that
that's an interesting question we have
some observations on that but I didn't
put them up the other thing is of course
to do in hypothesis testing in general
do without explicit knowledge of P
naught and P 1
now it won't be nice I don't think one
needs exactly the assumptions of D + + D
- it would be nice to dispense with them
right at the moment I have them for
technical reasons for things like
Gaussian they are not necessary and
another question how do these results
relate to work especially lower bounds
on planted problems and I will mention
some of those possible connections with
literature in the next slide this is
related work I don't know anything
directly related and maybe there'll be
some more pointers but there are two
things that are related that I want to
talk about one is a some joint work with
some Jewish translated into the notation
here you have a matrix now n by n matrix
a small fraction of the rows or signal
excellent rolls but everything except
those rows are noise normals ero 1 the
signal rules or a mild mixture of noise
and something differently now in that
paper it was just a variance was
different there was a lower bound there
as well as an upper bound the lower
bound is basis for statistical query
algorithm so the lower bound says the
following
if the chrisquared distance between
these two is finite and that turns out
to happen when Sigma squared is less
than 2 and epsilon is little epsilon is
less than 1 over root n no statistical
query test is ideal and this is based on
results a paper of Feldman at all that
you saw a reference to earlier in
aliases talk and but notice that this is
only for statistical curator so what our
lower bound theorem is is it's for any
possible test right it's for all
possible algorithms you get a lower
bound this is the statistical creators
however the set up is different because
you are given a number of roads now also
yeah that's that but we do we do assume
only that epsilon squared n is
little ol one this assumes epsilon
squared and is actually one over a power
of n now a sharper results in terms of
threshold is montaner acumen and they
tell you who proved the following they
also have an N by n symmetric matrix all
entries are normal 0 1 except the K BK
minor which is normal 1 1 and here the
threshold is sharper but only for a
particular class of algorithms is a
lower bound so I'll tell you what the
class of algorithms is so if case well I
get it says yeah if K is less than 1
minus epsilon root n it's long constant
I believe I don't know whether you can
go below constant but constant in the
paper no ideal test based only on the
spectrum so if I take this matrix and I
restrict my test to only look at the
eigenvalues then they prove it's a quite
a non trivial proof so it's a very
interesting proof mathematically they
prove that there's no ideal test right
but of this restricted class in fact for
greater than 1 plus epsilon there our
idea of this that's an easier part the
more going more farther afield okay so
you go that idea may be because you
really want to detect all the outliers
but you don't care about you don't need
little or one probability yeah so in
fact that should have been one of the
future questions so one can worry about
constant probability of error Francis I
should say some of the lower bounds like
this one even rules out probability of
error 3/4 yeah neat so one yeah
[Music]
sorry to end the talk but not so more
gentle I mean more afield for plaintiff
big problems we know that certain so
there's a particular distribution I
won't tell you what it is you all know
what it is probably the results can be
translated into our notation it'll say
that epsilon squared D if it is less
than one over N to the Delta positive
Delta so it's a bit stronger than
assuming little of one there is no ideal
test but again in a respected plus its
it could be the sum of squares it could
be some restricted class of tests that
do not exist in some sense this result
says that so it has it has the niceness
condition which is irritating that would
be nice but for then it says no
algorithm can do ideal test this right
suspect the connection with the
statistics ET theory literature there is
one your standard theorem that is in
graduate classes in quality which is
capital e theorem that as a corollary
gives basically a characterization of
which cases to product distribution
become neutral singular and is usually
singular which means that you can test
between them you know you can have an
ideal test so the setting is slightly
different in the sense that epsilon
doesn't depend on them but the
distributions are arbitrary and you have
no conditional
so it's complete I see so epsilon
depending on N and going to zero here is
an important thing because you can make
it dependent on I know you yes you can
make it dependent on I but in also so
for instance you can have n 0 1 and n 1
1 then they are not dependent on lie
only epsilon is going to 0 right in this
at this rate ok so we can check we can
check so there was a paper in 97 by
Ewing still which Wallace had a similar
model and analyze exactly issues the
text ability and the in statistical
language it's went to this the sequence
of distributions are contiguous or not
which allows to 0 1 eventually you value
is give you either the FP plus MN goes
to 0 or of the Sun goes to 1 and in the
weak model the difference is that
epsilon can go to 0 faster than 1 over
square root of n but the model that
people have looked at is when the
distribution P 1 does depend on n as
well so because best hotel in take your
example normal 0 1 and then instead of
normal 1 1 1 it would be normal let's
say squirtle to log N 1 yeah sure no
that is allowed here also you can know
that also the phase transition where
things are detectable with 51 and where
where they're not I'll give you the
reference okay so it's also an ideal
test is fpn mm both will go to zero okay
yeah give me an actually I said in the
beginning that this stuff you know
point out things that rather than ideal
test you get lots of simplification and
analysis because under i under possible
test type 1 or type 2 error for specific
false negative probabilities it becomes
equal to 1 minus total variation so it
means that you're looking for conditions
on there reached total variations
approaching 2 1 and that's much easier
than a noise okay III mean I don't know
what yeah yeah so I yeah three different
proofs of a few lines but every we
should check any other
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]